pay attendance and
is it on yet Martin
yeah right thank you and welcome to
anybody that's uh that's watching on the
uh the live stream hello
I don't know if they're talking to
myself uh but we will carry on now with
the with the agenda
I don't have to read any of that out
Ellen there were it's on the uh yes
chair if that would be possible
uh so he'd start off with apologies all
right no I meant the the Preamble oh
apologies for um for absence then I
don't think we were any we're all here
that's the case Joe thank you any
Declarations of Interest
don't thank you that's brilliant uh the
minutes of the last meeting and that's
just been pointed out to me that none of
those people who were at the last
meeting are now on the cabinet so
uh we'll just have to note those minutes
as they stand is that our talent uh yes
that's right Joe you've got two sets of
minutes there the one on the second of
March I think you'd be noting as no one
at that meeting is present today and
then you've also got the meeting of the
special cabinet held on the 25th of May
which you are able to approve yeah so
can we approve those that special
meeting then on the 25th of May please
and we're all in favor of that thank you
that's good uh item four then planning
environmental enforcement scrutiny
review
um
we've got three of these I do want to
play it Damon do you want to talk to him
or do it's a bit awkward because
obviously the chairs
are no longer should I just take it one
by one chair now okay if any buttons of
questions I can just answer them
okay so I'll stop the first one and
share this is the planning and
environmental enforcement student review
so the purpose of a report is to ask
cabinet to approve the organization
Security committee's review into
planning environmental enforcement so
just a bit of background the review aim
to understand how the planning
enforcement team worked with
environmental enforcement in other teams
understand how the planning enforcement
team functioned and carried out
multi-agency working
establish best practice and identify any
further improvements that could be made
so review panel met on five occasions
and consider variety of information
including a report from the head of
punning
which outlined the process investigating
reports and they looked at Key documents
such as the planning enforcement plan
and planning enforcement service reports
and interviews were held with a number
of officers so the full report attached
to appendix one sets out in more detail
the evidence gathered and a synopsis of
these expressed
including the review report
recommendations chair so happy to take
any questions on that
are there any questions for Damon
can't say anybody sat here
oh sorry
how do we want to uh progress this then
because there are recommendations there
right Lee I know you've got a thought
yeah if I could if I could share and
um Damon might be useful given where
we're at in the planning of the new
council plan uh not withstanding I know
you've got another couple to go through
but it might be useful to take the
approach the cabinet no
the findings and we filter in any
relevant uh recommendations into the
development of the new council plan
and the formation of the new scrutiny
groups they'll I'm sure they'll find the
home or because the old scrutiny
committees are no longer there and many
of the members are no longer there to
receive
feedback that might be the best way of
approaching it
actually I agree with that I think
and with all the three reports there's
nothing
uh mind-blowing any of them I think I
think we need to like look at the
recommendations and feed them in well at
least you said it and and wait doors are
we all right with that that that makes
sense so on that one then uh we will try
and find a place for uh those
recommendations in the plan going
forward
so that's that one and then we're on to
the item five which is a
again engagement with business
yes I'll just quickly present this one
chair so
um this is also to us cabinet to to
approve the growth scooting committee's
business Engagement review
so at its meeting on 24 January 2022 the
gross cruising Community agreed to
conduct a review into how the council
engaged with business so review aim to
understand how the council gauge with
local business
determine what would work well and what
not so well
listen to the views of local business
and suggest improvements to achieve
better engagement with businesses in the
district
so review panel here to a number of
stakeholders including external
businesses business advisor a business
consultant and internal officers
so a full report attached to appendix
one sets out in more detail the evidence
gathered and a synopsis of the views
expressed including review report
recommendations
once you're happy to take questions
share but I could just move into the
next one if you'd like me to to the
Leisure Provisions report
unless there's a question on that one
specifically
now a girl yeah no one
okay so this is the Leisure Provisions
um for all the Resident scrutin review
which is conducted by the community
scrutiny committee and so the review aim
to understand and assess what was being
done in the district to promote
healthier Lifestyles and improve
all-being in older residents understand
the demand from all the residents for
leisure Provisions provided by the
council
identify any opportunities to increase
participation and do memberships
evaluate what had been successful and
identify room for improvement
so review panel met on five occasions
and considered a variety of information
including the scene setting presentation
interviews with officers and data from
sport England the ons and the Derbyshire
Observatory the full report attached
appendix one sets out in more detail the
evidence gathered synopsis of a view is
expressed including the review report
recommendations thank you chair
yeah thank you Damon and and again but
with both those uh
I think they are good recommendations
that we can help build into
stuff going forwardly into that that's
fine
um
and just at this point I'd like to thank
all the scrutiny committees and and the
chairs and and people involved in all
these
scrutiny reports and Neil Damon for for
compiling them uh it is a obviously a
change of administration and we will try
and uh fit in as many as our
recommendations as we can because I
think they're all uh there's a way
across party
uh committees and I think they all work
quite well the ones that were involved
in were not to fairly non-political we
had a good debate around thinking so
hopefully we can carry that on going
forward and uh so if we're all right
with that again note the reports and and
thank everybody for the input thank you
okay thanks Damon thank you and come on
your Blues
that's it I hope to see you at several
grounds across the country mate
so here uh
item seven uh the adoption the revised
statement of community involvement
which is uh it's quite a long uh
documentary Eleanor went to present that
oops yeah
um just outlining that this is a report
on the proposed adoption of a revised
statement of community involvement
taking account of comments that were
received during publication uh public
consultation earlier this year
um so just a brief overview
um section one of the report sets out
some background
um clearly identifying the statutory
Duty that requires the production of
established Community involvement which
in itself should set out how the council
will engage with communities in both its
plan making functions and decision
taking
functions
um in terms of the local plan it's when
you're undertaking the preparation of a
demand plan document you must
demonstrate
that you've taken account of the
procedure set out in your statement of
community involvement so it is a very
important document in that context
um in relation to soundness of plan
making
the the council's current
statement Community endorsement was
adopted in 2014 and that's been overdue
for review now for for a number of years
um it wasn't done earlier because we're
in the process of of adopting the local
plan and it would have been seen to be
quite
um confusing for the public if we were
Consulting on on a new document it's
also enabled to take account of customer
feedback we've received in the plan
making process and we've fed that into
the the review
um
in addition to that there's been
increases in opportunities for digital
engagement and social media
um mainly as a result of the covid
pandemic as we had to change the way we
operated consultations during that time
so section two just sets out that the
main changes to this to the stem
Community involvement and the previous
version consisted of a number of
leaflets and we've drawn it all together
into a single document this time
and taking account of these increased
increased opportunities for digital
engagement but not at the expense of the
more traditional methods uh because we
acknowledge there are still sectors of
the community who don't who don't want
to or are unable to engage digitally by
making there's also a section on
neighborhood planning and that's been
enhanced to to reflect changes in in
guidance
in terms of planning applications the
changes are made are to bring them in
line with legislation
um in terms of who to consult what
groups of people to consult in relation
to different types of planning
application
so as I said the consultation took place
for six weeks during February and March
this year
paragraph 2.5 the document just sets out
some of the key methods that we used in
consultation and they're a good example
of the kinds of methods that we'll use
for future the base Baseline methods
would use certainly for future
consultation on development plan
documents although we would undertake
more face to face
consultation
um methods in that sense
and we received a total of 25 responses
to the draft statement of community
involvement and that doesn't sound like
a lot
um but we tend not to get a significant
the level of involvement
on these types of documents and the the
Nate the the detail of those are
summarized in appendix one to report
uh in the statement of consultation
along with an analysis and a response to
the issues raised we've taken on board
those
those comments where we can and that's
resulted in a few main changes to the
document which are mainly around
clarification
um and they're in relation to who
publicizing the consultation bodies and
the arrangements in place for
consultation on Lister building consent
applications and true proposals and also
signposting to other types of um
consent processes such as tree felling
licenses
so the changes proposed have been
incorporated into the version of this
the statement Community involvement
that's set out in appendix 2 of the
report and that's before you today
um recommended for your approval so it
can be published on the council's
website
thank you Ellen Stadium
no thank you very much for that Helen I
mean as you can see from appendix one
went out to dozens and dozens of people
and organizations uh we're given an
opportunity to respond
um as Ellen said there were 25 responses
from 11 organizations and two
individuals
um but it's only resulted in
really three
main changes one from drumfield Civic
Society one from somebody called Booth a
one from historic England uh that's just
um updated that and uh selling said it's
gone now from three leaflets into one
comprehensive document
thank you chair
you want to move the recommendations to
you yes I'll move the recommendations
thank you
are we all in favor of the
recommendations in one and two
right thank you
a battle and that's it
um
agent item items I've got none anybody
got any urgent items and then that leads
us to the exclusion of the public and
I've got to move that the public beach
loaded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following items of
business to avoid the disclosure to them
of exempt information information as
defined in part one of schedule 12a to
the Local Government Act 1972 as amended
by the local government access to
information variation order 2006.
the category of exempt information is
stated after each item
so
that's the end of the public bit of the
meeting yeah uh that's it our members
contend with the exclusion
yes
thank you